speaking of taking that risk he tweeted
when you have the choice between being a
Creator consumer or redistributor always
go for creation Now not only does it
lead to a more beautiful world but also
to a much more satisfying life for
yourself and don't get stuck preparing
yourself for the journey the time is
always now
so let me ask for advice what advice
would you give on how to become such a
creator
on Twitter in your own life
I was very lucky to be alive at the time
of the collapse of Eastern Germany and
the transition into Western Germany and
me and my friends and most of the people
I knew and were East Germans and we were
very poor because we didn't have money
and all the capital was invested in
Germany and they bought our factories
and shut them down because they were
mostly only interested in the market
rather than creating new production
capacity and so uh cities were poor and
in this repair and we could not afford
things and I could not afford to go into
a restaurant and order a meal there I
would have to cook at home but I also
thought why not just have a restaurant
with my friends so we would open up a
cafe with friends in a restaurant and we
would cook for each other in these
restaurants and also invite the general
public and they could donate and
eventually this became so big that we
could turn this into uh some
Incorporated form and it became regular
restaurant at some point or we did the
same thing with the music movies theater
we would not be able to afford to pay
um 12 marks to watch a movie but why not
just create our own movie theater and
then invite people to pay and we would
rent the movies
um in a way in which movie theater does
and but it would be a community movie
theater then which everybody who wants
to help can watch for free and builds
this thing and renovates the building
and so we ended up creating lots and
lots of infrastructure and I think when
you are young and you don't have money
move to a place where this is still
happening move to one of those places
that are undeveloped and where you get a
quick critical mass of other people who
are starting to build infrastructure to
live in and that's super satisfying
because you're not just creating
infrastructure but we are creating a
small society that is building culture
and ways to interact with each other and
that's much much more satisfying than
going into some kind of chain and
get your needs met by ordering food from
this chain and so on so not just
consuming culture but creating culture
and you don't always have that choice
that's why I prefaced it when you do
have the choice and there are many rules
that need to be played like we need
people who take care of radio
distribution in society and so on but
when you have the choice to create
something always go for creation it's so
much more satisfying and it also is this
is what life is about I think yeah
uh speaking of which you retweeted this
meme
of a life of a philosopher in a nutshell
it's birth and death and in between
it's a chubby guy and says why though
um
what do you think is the answer to that
well the answer is that everything that
can exist might exist and in many ways
you take an ecological perspective the
same way as when you look at human
opinions and cultures it's not that
there is right and wrong opinions uh
when you look at this from this
ecological perspective but every opinion
that fits between two human years might
be between two human years and
um so when I see in a strange opinion on
social media it's not that I feel that I
have a need to get upset it's often more
that a oh there you are and and your
opinion is incentivized then it's going
to be abundant and this when you take
this ecological perspective also on
yourself and you realize you're just one
of these mushrooms that are popping up
and doing their thing and you can
depending on where you chose to grow and
where you happen to grow you can
flourish or not doing this or that
strategy and it's still all the same
life at some level it's all the same
experience of being a conscious being in
the world and you do have some choice
about who you want to be more than any
other animal has that to me is
fascinating and so I think that rather
than asking yourself what is the one way
to be
um think about what are the
possibilities that I have what would be
the most interesting way to be that I
can be because everything is possible so
you get to explore this not everything
is possible many things fail most things
Fair
but uh often there are possibilities
that we are not seeing especially if we
choose who we are
to the degree we can choose
yosha you're one of my favorite humans
in this world Consciousness is to merge
with for a brief moment of time it's
always an honor it always blows my mind
it will take me days if not weeks to
recover
I and I already miss our chats
um thank you so much thank you so much
for uh speaking with me so many times
thank you so much for all the ideas you
put out into the world and
um I'm a huge fan of following you now
in this interesting weird time but going
through with AI so um thank you again
for talking today thank you Alex for
this conversation I enjoyed it very much